a popular R&B brand recently returned
from a successful three-city tour where
they played to at least 120 so at least
120,000 people my brain immediately says
that's greater than or equal to 120
thousand if they had an audience of
45,000 in Mesa and another 33,000 in
Denver how many people attended their
show in Las Vegas so let's say Las Vegas
I'll just use L for Las Vegas so the
number of people who attended the show
in Las Vegas plus the number that
attended the show in Mesa which is
45,000 plus the number of people that
attended their show in Denver which is
33,000 those are our three cities right
there Las Vegas Mesa and Denver that has
to be at least 120 thousand people or
another way interpreting that is greater
than or equal to 120 thousand so to
figure out how many people attended
their show in Las Vegas we just solve
for L on this inequality so if we
simplify this right-hand side we get or
sorry this left-hand side we get the
number of people in Las Vegas plus
what's forty-five thousand plus thirty
three thousand that is 78 thousand plus
78,000 is going to be greater than or
equal to 120 thousand now to isolate the
L on the left hand side of the
inequality we can subtract 78,000 from
both sides so minus 78,000 minus 78,000
on the left hand side these cancel out
and we're just left with the number of
people who attended the show in Las
Vegas is going to be greater than or
equal to 120 thousand minus 78,000 so
120,000 minus 80,000 is 40,000 that's
going to be another two thousand so the
number of people attend Las Vegas is
going to be greater than or equal to
42,000 people and we're done that's it